Hey guys, welcome back. Thanks for joining us today on the king of random
We've had a few videos using silicone rubber to make a mold of an object,
We already had and then cast it in a new kind of material.
This is a great way to make a copy of something that you already have.
We had a comment request from
"HundOhneStress as"
Saying you should take a vinyl record and cast it
in silicone then poured epoxy or resin in the mold to see if it sounds the same.
Well HundOhneStress as we think this is a great idea so we have a vinyl record and a record player,
We're going to try making a silicone mold of the record, and then cast it and resin to see if we can get a playable copy.
First we have to test that our vinyl records will play. This is a record of some Mozart music
♪ Music ♪
It can be fun messing with the settings on a record player alright
We now know our record play as well
So it's time to start prepping it to be molded so we can cast a copy of it
I have some oil-based clay
And I'm gonna be using that to make a border wall that goes around our record that will hold it in when we pour it
Onto the record so it doesn't flood the whole table
There's a slight chance that the vinyl record will try to float on the silicone
So I'm also going to use a little bit of clay on for points around the edges of the record to try and hold it
Down to the table these little bits of clay will show up in our casting which is too bad
But I don't know another way to make sure that our record doesn't go anywhere
They should easily trim off, and they shouldn't affect the playing of the music at all with the record secured in place
I'm now going to take some more clay and make a wall that runs all the way around it
Now let's mix up some silicone to pour onto our record
Because we don't want this to go too quickly and we want to make sure it gets into all the
Tiny grooves of the record. I am using the green catalyst which is much slower
Now we want to make sure that we get all of the air bubbles out of this silicone
So let's throw in the vacuum chamber and start sucking
Silicon should now be almost entirely bubble free
I'm just gonna clean off the record really quick
And then we'll start pouring it on probably more official ways you're supposed to clean records and someone out there is
Furious with me for using a paper towel all right. I think that's pretty good. Let's add our silicone
I'm starting by pouring the silicone right into the middle to let the rubber just sort of flow over the record
That's usually a good method to get it to get into all of the tiny little cracks and grooves
And courage it a little bit here
At this point our record is completely covered and our silicone is still going to keep flowing a little bit and reach the very edges
And settle itself down into a nice flat surface
This type of silicone and catalyst should take at least 12 hours to cure, so we'll come back tomorrow
And see how our mold has turned out
Our first layer of silicone is cured and dry and we could take it off now
But I want to be able to reinforce it just a little bit
So I am going to add another layer of silicone over the top of it to make it a little thicker and hopefully a little
Smoother this layer of silicone isn't going to be in contact with the record at all
So it doesn't matter if it says bubble free and perfect as the last one
So I'm not gonna use the vacuum chamber on it
I'm gonna use the red faster-acting catalyst this layer of silicone should only take about 45 minutes to cure so once it's ready
We'll de mold the record
Start by peeling all of the clay off and get it out of the way
This is an oil base to play it doesn't dry out. So this is still good to just save and use for another project
That's coming off and really nicely
POP
Beautiful, so if you get in really close you can see
The ridges from the record all the way around all of the tiny little grooves
are visible in the silicone
With this trim off the extra on the middle here. With our record successfully molded. I have two different types of resin
I'm going to try using to cast this record the two types of resin I'm using looked pretty similar
But this type takes about 15 to 20 minutes to cure and harden, and this type takes up to 24 hours
So I'm going to try both of them and see if we get any sort of good playable result from either one
I'm going to start with the fast-acting resin this mixes together in a one-to-one ratio, so equal parts of both, but first
I'm gonna lay down some
Protective cover because there's a good chance some of the resin will spill off of the record mold and onto the table
We also want to make sure that our mold is clear of any dust or dirt
Now before I start mixing and pouring my resin
I am gonna take a little bit of the oil-based clay and try and add some barriers
Where I have these marks in the silicone this is just in an effort to make sure that the resin doesn't run down
Through those gaps and onto the foil too much because I do need it to build up on the record a little bit
And the clay isn't really going to stick to the silicone much
But hopefully it will stay on there enough to make a difference
Now I'm going to pour the first half into the second half and mix it up. This resin does start to cure pretty quickly
So I'm gonna have to be fairly quick in my mixing all right. I think that's pretty well mixed now
I'm gonna pour it onto the mold
My resin is already starting to thicken up a little bit not pouring out of the cup as easily as it was when I started
yeah, rigid me it was like a
Warm syrup. Oh there we go it. It's barely even liquid anymore
now the resin in the cup had more mass of the resin all stuck together as a result its own heat would speed up the
Catalyzation process turning it rigid the resin on the record mold is a lot more spread out
So it's not holding a heat as well, so it's not catalyzing quite as quick. You can see that while this is basically
Solid at this point it's still flexible, but it's not sticky anymore these little drips over here
They're still quite gummy and even a little bit liquid
So let's give this resin 15 to 20 minutes to cure before we take it out of the mold
Clean up the edges and fix the hole in the center before we see if it will play on our record player all
Right our resin is now mostly cured. It's definitely cured enough that I feel comfortable pulling it out of the mold
Let's see how it turned out
Now while the resin is still a little bit soft. I'm gonna try and use a razor blade and trim off these excess spillage areas
Interesting parts visible where there were a lot of bubbles near the surface,
That's one of the downsides of this type of resin,
It does tend to get a lot of bubbles and because it catalyzes so quickly there isn't time to put it in a vacuum. chamber
All right,
I'm going to try putting our original record down on to the player and
Then put our cast record on top of at the original record should hold it rigid enough,
That it stays flat.
It's playing!!!
ITS PLAYING! Oh my gosh.
Nice going, Texas.
It's worse audio quality definitely listen to all those crackles and pops
Scratchy stereo noises getting in there interference definitely but
It's playing on our molded and cast
record oh
There that's so cool. Oh
The audio quality is so much worse it's making scratching sounds every second, but that's so cool
I think it's also quieter interestingly enough
I'm gonna try to play the same spot on both the copy and the original it's gonna be a little tricky
But we'll try there in the blank spot
Well it does play it's a playing record
That is so funny. Oh my gosh
So I didn't really have a lot of high hopes that this resin would work very well
It casts very quickly it gets fairly warm
And I didn't think it would pick up quite enough detail to really be able to make out that it was music
I thought maybe we would get some scratching noises from it, but the fact that we can definitely tell
What music is being played is amazing! We have achieved a level of success with our first casting now
we're going to try our slower resin
which is actually going to get put in the vacuum chamber to remove all of the bubbles and then it takes as much as 24 hours
to cure we start out the same way by mixing up even portions of our side a and side B resin
I've also got a new color that I'm going to try adding to this resin
All right, I'd say that's now evenly mixed you can see how many bubbles mixing it introduced into that resin
It's just completely full of bubbles at this point. That's why we're gonna throw in the vacuum chamber and suck them all out
I'm not sure this one will get high enough that I have to drop it or not
It's not super consistent with this resin. You can see some of the bubbles starting to get pulled out.
Ooh! Excellent.
Didn't have to drop the pressure at all now
It's just sucking air out of the resin
Looks like boiling candy actually looks a lot like when we made the candy for the thumb suckers looks pretty much
just like the boiling sugar
There are still a few bubbles rising up, but I think at this point
That's just the alcohol from the ink dye that I used boiling in the low pressure
I'm gonna slowly let some air back in see what happens to all those bubbles I bet they just disappeared
Try and get to the very edge on all the parts of the record this time
so we don't have that little gap that we had on our first casting
Alright I think that's going all the way to the edges everywhere it is spilling out in a couple of spots
but that shouldn't be a big problem does look like right here. It's probably a little bit thin
you can maybe see that the green of the silicone is showing through a little bit more right there
But it is still covered
and I think it will still turn out just fine and now our second type of resin is cured
I did have something odd happen
I pointed out where there was a thin spot in the resin while it was curing a hole did form in that thin spot on
The mold I mixed up a small second batch of the clear resin
And I poured that on as a sort of patch
Where it had gone so thin that you could actually see the silicone right through it
And then I reinforced a couple other small spots that looked like they were pretty thin as well
But at this point everything is cured, and it's ready to be de-molded.
Alright, let's see...
Oh. Looks like it's coming off the actual record just fine,
Which is what we were hoping for.
Right here, you can see the patch
Where I filled in the gap and I didn't use any yellow dye in this spot.
So that's why we have sort of a clear spot in the middle, and then you can see the a little bit of the texture
Around the edges where it was red.
It doesn't like to spread super nice and thin
But I don't think that should affect a plane because that's just on the back side on the front. It's just
Perfectly smooth looks like uninterrupted record just like you would want to see it
*nate just cutting off the excess stuff* While you are here, here is some music.
I'll turn on the power...
lay our record down. It is, I think, maybe not a hundred percent cured
it feels like it might be a little flimsy, but it's not much different from an actual vinyl record.
so we'll try it without putting the actual vinyl record underneath it for support. See how it goes.
:/
Not bad :|
This is kinda weird. :/
It's playing pretty well, there's a little bit of static in the background
But there's not nearly as much of the popping and crackling that happened with our first test.
I think we definitely got a much better result with this second resin.
I'm gonna move it and see what happens if it goes right over the thin spot.
Doesn't really seem to be affecting it any I don't think it sounds about normal.
Maybe there is a little warble as it hits it--
Just as a test. I'm gonna try putting normal record underneath our casting just to make sure it stays up nice and flat
And it's held in place
There you go, that is working
Pretty darn well. I'd say like I said there's a little bit of static noise
More than the original
There you have it you can make a mold of a record and cast it in resin and make something that plays
which is incredible to me especially that this first one worked
I didn't think this first resin would be high enough quality that it would get the details to really pick up the sound but it did
you can absolutely tell what music is playing on both records our second slow cure resin did give us a better result but
the first one's not terrible
Special thank you to YouTuber "HundOhneStress As" for your suggestion that we try this check the youtube inbox
we're sending you 25 bucks remember that if you have any cool ideas you want to see us
try, let us know down in the comments if we use your idea for a video. We'll send you $25
I'm really happy. I got to try this experiment with you guys
Thanks for joining us for this project and we'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then
This is probably the least efficient and most expensive form of music piracy ever invented. I drew on the foil the resin spilled over it
and it just lifts it right up I
Got a gold record
Hey guys, it's Grant here, I just want to pop in and say hello
You guys are wonderful Nate, and I are incredibly grateful for the way. You keep supporting us, so that's pretty much
It just want to give you a quick. Thank you. I'll see you in the next video
Subtitles by Hubz. Big Thanks for the grammar checks Nub! (yes that is his name)